hi everyone thanks for coming out
um today I'm going to talk about deep
learning for a Time series in practice
uh I guess just a little bit more about
me uh I've now been working with kind of
Time series and using deep learning on
it for I think actually like six years
now maybe ever since I was back in
college was when I first started playing
around with deep learning models on time
series and since then I've used it and
pretty much every job I've had used it
to forecast Healthcare data patient
length will stay used it to predict
demands and retail stores
um you and now using it to do anomaly
detection
um on cyber security data so it's
definitely been a long way and
I always like to think I've learned
something about it along the way so um
let's get started so um
first thing uh I'm the offer and kind of
creator of a deep learning for time
series forecasting framework uh open
source I hope everyone checks it out
after this a lot of the examples will be
using it it's called flow forecast
because I actually originally created to
forecast streams and river flows but
then I generalized it to work in a type
of temporal data so um
obviously I think one of the top deep
learning for time series Frameworks out
there the best in every way which is
kidding there are plenty of good
Frameworks out there but I do think
we're unique in how we use configuration
files and make it easy to spin up
different experiments and test lots of
different models and different
configuration settings
um so yeah I do hope you'll check it out
afterwards okay so overview of the
tutorial first I'm going to go over some
background then I'm going to go uh on
about challenges and obstacles before we
jump into some coding examples
um because there are lots of challenges
I think that particularly when using a
deep learning model
um I guess it's true in most time series
problems in general but particularly
using deep learning that people
sometimes Overlook and don't think about
long enough ahead of time so then that
leaves the problems down the road
um then I'll go into the tutorial
section
um
and go over a couple different tutorials
maybe even uh add in uh one there
Depending on time then I'll discuss some
future directions kind of where I think
it's the feel as a whole is going and
kind of what I think that means
individually for people in Industry
um and how to keep up and then we'll
have a long kind of q a because uh
um yeah I don't think I'm going to go
over an hour probably so we'll probably
have a lot of time for questions at the
end
um so some brief history I always like
to think about things historically like
uh even like six or seven years ago
um basically all that people weren't
really looking at Deep learning for time
series and if they were they were
looking at basically just lstms and grus
um
over time as kind of the NLP field as a
whole has progressed I think the talk
before me talked about NLP a bit too uh
more of the NLP techniques have kind of
crossed over which kind of makes sense
because they're both kind of sequence
models in a respect so more ideas like
attention
um and then later on Transformers being
added uh and now most recently we're
seeing a lot of graph neural networks
unfortunately they're still very hard to
use
but uh but yeah it's kind of advancing
along that way
um not that and and one of those things
too I think is interesting in Time
series and we'll get to is none of these
techniques are really obsolete because
time series is a lot more fragmented
um some of these things like sometimes
an lstm might be the best thing to use
or a GRU which I don't really think is
the case in uh NLP now um usually you're
always going to use some Burt model or
some variant of it
um so yeah we'll we'll go over that
um so now some challenges obviously
formulating the problem initially is a
very hard thing and I'll get to that in
a second then you know Finding picking
the right model since it is a more
fragmented landscape
fitting the model always tons of issues
and finally ensuring the model is robust
all these are
fairly difficult
um things but we'll dive into each
individually first I'll just clarify a
bit of terminology
I bet most of you are probably familiar
with this but forecasting we're
generally trying to predict the target
variable at a future time step
um it could be
20 time steps into the future
um at each time step into the future you
know up to 20 it could be it could be
variable length but we're trying to
predict the actual value in general
um or there are some times when you
assign it to quantile
um like with a quantile loss but
generally we're trying to predict the
actual value and classification we're
trying to label
assign a label to kind of a sequence of
different time uh time steps and anomaly
detection basically it's just a extreme
case of binary classification but it's
treated a little bit differently in
terms of what loss function and other
stuff you might pick it's often treated
a bit differently in literature and
types of data sets
um and yeah there can be overlap between
these and you can do these jointly so um
we'll get into that in a bit
um Okay so
so yeah I mean one of the first things I
think for an industry person uh to think
about is how will
um
realize I didn't type that right well it
should be how will myself or my
customers use the output of the model
um so that that's kind of the big thing
because like of course on a lot of the
you know these state-of-the-art models
you see coming out of the major research
conferences they're just trying to beat
some pre-established benchmarks so they
don't really think about that too much
um but this this is of course really
important and the kind of the central
scene so
um
so and particularly in forecasting I've
seen a lot of times where like we
optimize models to try to predict the
exact value but in actuality basically a
range of values it could be in is more
useful
um uh you know I worked for a bit doing
covid forecasting with an epidemiologist
and it was much more important to see
kind of uh what range it would be in at
different times and what the underlying
drivers of that factor were than the
actual value so that's always something
to I think to think about
um
then also like kind of the properties of
your data like uh
we generally deal with very messy data
sets
um and so there are a bunch of things
that can throw off kind of the neat kind
of picturesque forecasting model or
classification model you see things like
variable length sequences
um irregular sampling and we're missing
and large amounts of missing values
can all be kind of issues so those are
all uh all these exploratory data
analysis is uh useful in kind of
disrespect
um likewise the first thing we face is
to how to incorporate uh additional
information because like again most of
the these benchmarks there's existing
data set you try to beat The Benchmark
on that data set but in reality like uh
in the in kind of real world problems we
have a lot of auxiliary data we could
incorporate and a lot of additional
features we could incorporate and it can
sometimes be hard to think about how to
do that into kind of different fixed
size deep learning models and how to
create do I create an embedding do I do
all this
um so this is also something that is
good to think about I don't have an
exact answer of just how to do it but
something to think about when um
uh one doing time series work
forecasting or classification industry
um okay here's where I was
first so basically as I was saying
before the time series forecasting
landscape is kind of fractured
um
uh this is uh this is already somewhat
of an old study
um but like I found it really
interesting because uh you probably want
to see something it's similar in NLP
there's this thing called the Monash or
uh time series forecasting repository
which showed different models and their
benchmarks and stuff on different data
sets so there are a whole bunch of
different data sets here and you see
different deep models and kind of
vanilla models and different deep models
perform better on different data sets
it's the bolded model
um I mean I'm not going to go over each
and every one of these but just by
looking over this you can see it's very
fragmented Which models there's no
single model that seems to outperform
every other model under data sets and
likewise just anecdotally I've seen
times where like a simple model with
attention like works better than a trans
like you know a really big Transformer
model
um
uh
uh so um that's definitely something to
I guess think about
um and look into
so okay there's a freezing problem
okay so yeah a case in point was the
Informer it was the new state-of-the-art
model released at a triple
AI 2020 it won the best paper so ours
left and must be good
um but I quickly find found myself
banging my head against the wall trying
to get it to work to actually produce
usable forecasts
um
so
so yeah so for instance with that
basically
even though it was state of the art in
that respect uh
um oh by the way with flow forecast as
I'll get to in a bit we log all the
results all the results get logged the
weights and biases which is an
experiment tracking tool
um so I see uh
to see like the forecast with it we're
just basically even after a lot of hyper
parameter tuning they were just kind of
awful
um
uh so anyways I kind of but I I was oops
I need to figure out how to get back to
the regular slide
until I haven't been presenting much
do we oh there
um yeah I was determined to use it but
eventually and I even bypass simpler
models like for instance d-a-r-n RNN
which is just a simple RNN with
attention I think I have some examples
or yeah
um you know even though that out of the
box kind of worked much better
um oh wait this was this was that
um
hey a big example there
oh yeah so see this was what the United
arnn produced obviously a lot better
um though not that as we'll go into a
bit it wasn't actually
um doing everything right but
just out of the box it worked a lot
better but I was so set on using the
Informer that I wasted tons of time and
hours thinking oh this should be able to
outperform this model because it
performed better on these experimental
data sets
um so that's just kind of a case in
point of something not to do
um
common issues common issues when
training the model
um oh I don't think I actually
Incorporated the link
on here
um but uh some comments things I see
this is actually one of my most uploaded
I think answers on stack Overflow ever
so I take some pride in it but basically
common things people run into
um and this person was actually asking
why their training loss was Nan for
until SPM was the biggest one is always
check your data you want to always
ensure that there are no missing or null
values because like in a neural network
even a single missing or null value will
cause all your output of the neural not
to be null
depending on what thing you're using the
obverse thing is is uh is you can you
always want you generally always want to
scale your values because if you pass in
really big time series values to a
neural network over time it will cause
the gradient to explode and then that
point you get uh another error which is
usually infinite losses which I kind of
note there
um
lower learning rate uh as we'll see
generally works better
so I usually start with a lower learning
rate and I might turn it up
um
yeah the reason I bring this up is just
because these seem to be common pitfalls
that happen to people a lot
um we do have some automated checks and
full forecasts so these don't happen to
you
um there but uh if you are training a
model outside of our framework or I
think there are even certain times even
in our framework these have uh we don't
capture necessarily all the messy data
these are very common things uh that can
go wrong
um
so common issues yeah I should put a
link there
um the other thing is metrics alone
don't mean your model will perform well
um basically and I've seen this a lot
happen a lot um basically uh actually
just based on that other
um
uh well this was oh wait yeah I already
had this tab open anyways so yeah I kind
of wrote this report on forecasting this
River flow and so these models did some
of the models at least seem to perform
well at forecasting but actually when
including this model when you look at
what they're actually looking at in
terms of features this is a feature we
automatically build into flow forecast
is these shaft plots you see that none
of them are really using precipitation
and this somewhat makes sense because in
this data set this is kind of a des a
river essentially in the desert and it
doesn't normally rain but you can see
none of the models are really wording
that precipitation is something to
factor in uh when forecasting they're
mainly using the temperature the
existing CFS and the dew point so that
basically when you do have a large rain
event
um
you have a large rain event where
basically
the river
yeah where where the river shoots up to
a really high value at once the model
doesn't really respond accordingly
um and even though they model kind of
the downward Trend that happens when
there isn't a lot precipitation going on
um they can kind of understand that they
don't really understand that
precipitation is tied to this uh to this
huge jumping kind of that's kind of hard
to see but basically the actual value of
the river there
shoots way shoots way up like way up
here and the model eventually starts to
go up there but uh in that case
um though in other cases it doesn't this
was actually where I study kind of
comparing four models but anyways I
guess the takeaway of that um
there is a link in the slide so people
want to read through this whole report
some point they can but the main
takeaway for that is just don't always
trust uh your metrics and always look at
what kind of what values your model is
using when forecasting so you can even
you should even look at those stat plots
and even play with different values of
variables you know are dependent
um
okay so now we're actually going to jump
into some code
um and some code examples of using flow
forecast to forecast
um and I have these are publicly
available on Kegel kaggle so anyone can
go back and see these later
um I don't know if I'll actually run
this now or not
um
or
do people want to actually see this run
in real time of course okay okay I'll
I'll run I'll run through this again
um so basically here again this is in a
notebook
um
at the moment while you can install flow
forecast using pip too the moment I've
I'm installing most places using the
master Branch uh just because I've been
pushing a lot of stuff to master
recently and haven't necessarily
released into a package which I probably
should do
um but uh but anyways that's basically
just downloading and installing full
forecasts which would also be done by a
pip install
um
so we can run that it will run in that
cell generate a lot of output then
basically
um so this data set it's a
um for all things considered it's a
pretty simple data set
um it's not uh
there there aren't we don't really have
the problem with a lot of missing values
we don't have tons of variables
um the only thing we really do have
um that's somewhat okay finally started
running the only thing we don't really
have that we don't really have
um that a lot of
uh that that might be challenging is it
does have different regions in it
um so right now
um in this first example we only train a
single model to our region
um
uh in in one of the uh I actually have
different examples of how to do this so
um one of the later examples I'll
actually show one where we train a model
in multiple regions at once
um but anyways so this one we're just uh
training Wonder region I think this is
going to run
uh it's still installing
um so once that runs basically I'm just
doing basic data
typical data stuff so here as I said
we're limiting to one geography because
obviously we can't just feed in the
whole DF with a bunch of different
geographies at once unless we
specifically tell the model we're
forecasting on all those which makes it
more complicated so um
and uh and I'm also only looking at a
single type but this is another actually
interesting thing to think about is that
oftentimes when forecasting we're trying
to forecast on different regions and
different resolutions so we might be
forecast
um well at least most people probably
work with
some geospatial data for instance when I
worked in retail we had different stores
and we tried to forecast for different
stores or you could uh forecast for like
a whole County of all the stores in the
county so like deciding or I guess your
geospatial region if you do have this
type of data is sometimes useful because
sometimes you might not have data for
each
location or a law of it so you might
actually want to combine so so like a
higher resolution and try to do it on I
guess the everything at once
um
anyway so that's kind of what these
cells are just doing uh also I'm only
forecasting one type at a time
um in this example because uh different
types have different costs so
um
I don't want to confuse
this fair this is this will be a fairly
simple model
um but I don't want to confuse it with
different types I'm trying to forecast
two types at the same time
um now we get to the kind of the core
part flow forecast and why I think we're
kind of a unique framework everything in
full forecast we use a configuration
file and this helps both with
reproducibility because we always know
what exactly hyper parameters we're
using in the configuration file because
uh as we run this the configuration file
itself will get logged to weights and
biases so we'll always know which runs
generated which results
um so this is basically the
configuration file here I'm just using
the model named d-a-r-n-n which is
basically an RNN with attention well
actually it's
it's actually usually an lstm or a Gru
with uh with attention but they called
it RNN but I can be either uh one so
here are there are model parameters
uh the so we're here we're using
essentially six time series in total
we're using the average of price the
total volume and these are different
amounts
um
um a bag sold it actually yeah oh yeah
yeah
so um
so yeah yeah actually yeah here we're
using uh actually yeah we're actually
using five
time series here I think but we plug in
six to the AR and M because the sixth
um Dr arnn has this work where it's with
six that you usually uh is the is
basically you have to pass an extra
value to that for the Target most miles
and flow forecasts though you pass the
exact number
um there that's uh but it is documented
here
um so any case that's how how you do it
where you're going to use
um these are fairly standard values but
these could as we'll see in other
examples be tuned by a hyper parameter
search so this is the hidden size for
the encoder this is the hidden size for
the decoder
um the number of output features is one
because we're only forecasting one
target here
um and then we're we're essentially
taking four historical time steps to
forecast one future time step here so
we're taking five historic ones and uh
and uh yeah forecasting one time step
into the future
um these finish running
so that's basically
um that part of
the configuration file
um
again these can be changed so
yeah this can sometimes be a tricky
hyper parameter to figure out how many
time historical time steps will make for
the best forecasts because at a certain
point like in the very far past it might
stop mattering and if you put when say
like we did like a hundred of these like
after a while like some of those really
far ones the model might think are
important but they're actually not
so I usually usually have optimize this
in a hyper parameter search
but here again I'm just using five for
kind of a simple example
um
now the data set params
uh similar we just specify
um
the batch size
and all that train end train start
Target column sort column
um
some additional parameters like if we
want to scale the output oh wait
yeah I misread my own configuration file
here the reason actually why this uh was
six times series and not five even
though they're five specifies here we're
actually generating an additional
parameter so we're using the month as a
numerical feature so actually in flow
forecast you specify both the columns in
um you specify both the columns
uh from the data frame you want to use
and then also if you want to generate
what numerical features automatically
you can do that with like by including
this feature param
um I like to do that because then I
don't have to do a bunch of manual
things slicing up this thing here
um and these this is these are weekly
the data here is also reported on a
weekly level of granularity so that's
why I'm using month as kind of a feature
but uh you could also
um if if the data had it like in the
feature params include something like
the day as a numerical feature or even
something like the day of the week and
all you'd have to do to do that would be
to like uh include day like numerical
you can even do our
um to it all depends on the granularity
and then the basically our code will
automatically generate those features
for you but yeah then you do have to
remember to add essentially however many
you are to the number of times series
when initializing the model
so yeah I actually misread that there uh
anyways going down we have training
parameters
[Music]
um
actually I'll just run this cell now so
this thing can get started training
um what and then we can keep talking why
we while it trains
um
uh so yeah then again we have wording
rate here I'm specifying a fairly low
learning rate 0.001 it's not the lowest
some models uh particularly big
Transformer models you'd actually
probably want to go 0.001
um because those take a really if you
ramp up the learning rate too early
they'll uh
they'll they'll fail to converge at all
um anyways that's kind of the
configuration file all this is documents
you on our basically we have a
conference page of document ation where
we document how to use configuration
files
um
uh
basically training it goes over the
different parameters and there are a
bunch of different parameters you can
add and the nice thing is is like if you
want to change something like say how
you're scaling the data all you have to
do is change that scalar parameter if
you want to add more columns so if you
started off really simple we're just
using two of these you just delete these
columns and change the number here so
it's pretty simple to like play around
with a lot of different settings
um
so I think that cell below did finish
running or it is running so basically
results we have it set up
um to automatically log the weights and
biases you can create your own weights
and biases account for free
um
for free there are also private settings
on weights and biases so if you have a
confidential data you can make the
private all these are public so anyone
can look at them but you can make them
private
um there are there are teams too for
companies on weights and biases uh
as well um I mean I'm not pitching
weights and biases but I do like to use
it for logging experiments because it
does make stuff easier so that's why we
built in kind of a native integration
here
um so so there we can see some of the
loss the validation lost
um
didn't necessarily go down as quick as
the loss loss
um and then you can scroll through here
see different heat maps of what the
model is looking at
um
so it looks like most of the case that's
using the total volume uh sold as a
heavy predictor
um it's not doesn't look like it's
really using these other features at all
really
um but shap isn't 100 reliable
um
anyways but then again then here again
we have our prediction versus the actual
um so these are what the model predicted
looks like the model predicted pretty
straight
um this isn't that off this is a
predicting I guess 1.5 here it's
predicting 1.22 here
um again remember we didn't really tune
any of these parameters at all we just
kind of uh
these are kind of a default setting that
I was using
um
and we're not really using a confidence
interval otherwise you can also generate
more plots easily too if you want to
look at it on different dates oh yeah I
forgot to mention the configuration file
that determines what date uh in the test
set it will plot on so like here the
daytime start is like November 1st 2020
so that's where it's plotting from on
the test set that's where these
predictions are starting on
um when it's plotting here
um and then hours to forecast is
actually this should really just be time
steps to forecast but this is a remnant
of when it was strictly used for River
flow forecasting
um I should probably change that in the
code base at some point but this is
basically now just a number of time
steps you want to forecast so in this
case it's actually forecasting
um
the other cool thing is we can actually
specify multiple metrics at once so here
we're actually uh
why we're actually recording free
metrics at once of course you can only
optimize on one metric at once uh
um or else well you can actually do it
with multiple ones too but you probably
wouldn't want to do that uh but here we
can specify multiple metrics for it to
plot on the test set so there we do see
things like we see the dilate loss we
see that uh L1 loss
um and we have an MSC loss too
um
so uh so yeah that and then like
likewise then if you do say like ten
thousand or a thousand runs of different
parameter config configurations you
could then sort by like
the different losses and get the one
with the best gloss so
um so for instance then you could add a
filter and sort by these or yeah
actually you want to sort here
um so that so that's another reason we
walked away some biases automatically is
it just makes it easier to
um
deal if runs and things like that
um so so there we see that um and then
again as I said it's pretty easy to use
our built-in plot functions if you want
to plot additional plots so for instance
here
um now let's try like plotting this is
still in the test set
um too
um you would want to check of course
like you're actually plotting dates in
the test set here here actually a
divided train and test up by the length
of the data set so
um this is the train start train and
valid start valid in
um
uh you can just specify numericals
things there too
um and then uh so yeah now we can plot
here
we should be able to see a plot
we'll just regenerate it
um yeah again yeah
it's doing this sometimes other weird
stuff happens to you with various random
seeds
um
we turn this using MSE actually
um oh we actually trained it using
dilate
um
so but yeah uh where sometimes actually
random seeds can influence how the model
works too so I think I've run this same
configuration a couple times but gotten
slightly different results just by how
um it's been initialized and that
particularly happens on smaller data
sets like once we like trim this down
we're only trading on 306 rows so
basically uh
the the initialization of the model
weights will have more impact on a
larger data set that will be less of the
case
um and you can actually we're building
something to actually free seeds
automatically but you can set the scene
manually in pie torch I'm using your
Samsung too
um anyways that that was kind of a very
simple example
um I have a couple more examples
um on the same data set of doing
slightly different models
um
remember where I put them exactly
um okay yeah here here I actually I
won't run through all this uh exactly
but here again
um
we changed the model slightly basic same
pre-processing here but here we actually
use what's called a probabilistic so we
use a probabilistic deep model so we're
actually predicting kind of the the mean
and standard deviation uh instead so
similarly we have our same kind of
configuration file this is basically the
same but here we're using a Drew which
is another model available and we're
making it probabilistic so we're saying
this probabilistic parameter to True
um and uh yeah pretty much the rest is
the same
um through here uh you know you do that
you train it
um but yeah the the nice thing about a
probabilistic model is then it basically
at the end it creates a distribution and
then you can sample the distribution so
then when we look at these plots we can
see
um you know here here's the actual
average price here's what the mile
predicted but here are the upper and
lower bounds
uh of the of essentially the
distribution so
um again we didn't really do that much I
didn't really do that much extensive
hyper parameter tuning on it so you can
see that the lower bound is kind of
ridiculous since it's in the negative
Zone uh but uh but it does show the
model is pretty uh somewhat is pretty
certain that the uh this is where
essentially the average price will fall
um
you know hopefully with parameter tuning
we could narrow that so this is the plot
on another date here are predictions not
that far off actually and then here's
the upper bound where it's the max price
could be in the lower bound
two
um so that's kind of a probabilistic
example
there
um
and I have one more example using that
same one
um code
um
where I think I call them multi-region
oh yeah yeah oh yeah multi-region
Transformer
um so here's here I actually use a
Transformer model
um here I do take out the Transformer
um the thing I do different here is I
actually then predict on two kind of
geographic regions at once
um so here I predict both on I think
it's Chicago and Detroit
um it's still a little messy using flow
forecast for predicting multiple
geospatial regions at once
um though I'm hopefully I have a PR
that's going to simplify it so you still
have to do a lot of the features by hand
so here I merge them and I kind of
create this combined thing into this uh
like income combined data frame that
encompasses both the Chicago and Detroit
sings
um and then I just like
map it to this so this is Chicago CH
stands for Chicago BT stands for Detroit
then I feed these features in
um
to the model so and then and then again
of course since now we're forecasting
for two things our output Dimension is
two and then every model has slightly
different parameters that you put in
model params you can see those in our on
our read the docs page but of course
here we're now forecasting for two
Targets so we put two there
um and yeah then we basically just run
this again
uh and again we'll plot some of the
results but now we'll actually have two
plots
um
so this is uh oh yeah the other thing I
did too here is I added a confidence
interval so even on non-probalistic
models using Dropout you can do a
confidence interval because Dropout
zeros some of the layers I don't know
how familiar people are with Dropout but
there was actually a deep learning paper
like a couple years ago that argued drop
out is kind of a way of almost doing
Bayesian uh
Bayesian kind of inference on deep
learning models I don't know how true
that actually is but you can get a
confidence interval somewhat at least
using Dropout
so here
so here I do put Dropout at point one
the bigger the Dropout the more of the
layer it zeros out randomly so the more
Dropout you put in generally the bigger
the confidence interval you'll see
um
and then you'll also also drop out can
help her
vent overfitting on a particularly small
data sets
um then we also have this number of
prediction samples per amp so basically
it it runs the model 20 times through
and then it creates that confidence
interval
um
it's still a bit different than the
probabilistic one because the
probabilistic one we're actually
training them all explicitly to predict
uh the the distribution and the STD
using the actual loss function this
we're still just training it to predict
one target but then we're running it
multiple times later to get the
confidence interval of the dropout so
we're not really training it to be a
problem but anyways here here's kind of
this this is the confidence interval
um here is this one Detroit or Chicago
now I should probably label that here
um so this is
um oh yeah this is Detroit looks like it
did Better Learning Chicago at least a
bit but I didn't really get that Valley
there
um
didn't do that well in that part of
Detroit well I I think this is important
too like in Time series too many people
too often people don't just like look at
their metrics finally or they look at
one kind of sherry-picked example of
like how the plots are but really
looking at different Squad plots and
seeing how it performs
under different kind of uh date times is
kind of interesting
um so yeah a disadvantage here is it
doesn't doesn't really seem to get that
price is high here
um
but yeah uh but yeah often when you plot
like I found even the best of the models
multiple times like some of them will be
way off and then you have to try to dig
in to figure that out and stuff
um okay so so again as I said uh these
this I didn't really optimize in terms
of hyperproof
too
um okay so that kind of covers the
avocado Fork
14. oh yeah I had a actually I had an
example that I sought worked of Time
series classification because flow
forecast can actually do time series
classification then I realized actually
uh just the other day that this was uh a
bad example because uh
um as I was creating it I realized my
Roc curves were all over the place and
then I realized actually this these
times this these human activity
recognition data set the human
activities of the lengths of the number
of frames that each are not are not
um
are basically irregular so sometimes
they'll be 20 frames sometimes they'll
be 30 frames so basically the model is
learning nothing
um but if the frames were the equal
length this is how you'd set it up
and you can see
you basically set it up a classification
again
um you'd have you'd set number of
targets equal to the number of classes
you use this General classification
loader
um and then yeah pretty similar except
then you'd use like a cross entropy loss
for classification
um
but yeah basically here the major
problem was and we'll see that basically
the model didn't really learn anything
over time because the ROC curves don't
really change that much as the models
being trained they basically stay pretty
static uh and uh in the in the loss is
very funky and this is because
essentially
um
and it goes back to one of my earlier
points about uh
about knowing your data because here I
was just like oh I'll cook up this
example really quickly I mean as I just
assumed all the lengths of the different
activities so there are these different
activities standing walking
Etc would be the same length uh and in
reality they weren't
um so actually probably in reality
forecast should throw an error here it
should throw an error message or a
warning
um warning people about this uh so it
just doesn't run but uh again that's a
good example of why you have to look at
your data carefully I guess
[Music]
um
wait but yeah you could use this as a
template uh you know I often will copy
config files
um and then just plug in my parameters
to them so like if you were doing a
classification problem where the
um where the length of the sequences
you're classifying are the same this
would uh this template would kind of
work for that
obviously it doesn't work in this case
though okay so that was the bad
classification oh
um
so now we can go to another full Piper
this is kind of a full hyper parameter
sweep
um I did a while ago and because it's a
really long slinging took forever to run
uh
uh we obviously won't run this full
thing or we could start running it but
uh it won't finish but basically here
again uh this is this is a forecasting a
river flow first of all so I have these
uh let's show you some of the data
um to give you an idea
um so we have these like big things of
river flows
um
translation
I don't know if I can hold that up
oh lit okay there so um basically we
have precipitation temperature dew point
uh things like ice secretion I don't
really use those columns and then we
have the
um the cubic footage
per second
um which is
where am I notebook go
I don't know how kiago is exactly you're
rendering this
um but anyways from that file we
basically again select the cubic footage
per second
the precipitation
um
as relevant columns and then we're
trying actually here because we weren't
necessarily know what these would be
ahead of time I'm using all these as
Target columns so here this model tries
to forecast all of these at once
um which is is obviously harder to do
though in some cases the data set is big
enough
um then these can actually be pretty
good like auxiliary columns
um because uh the model can learn better
learn the Relationships by forecasting
multiple ones at once
um
I don't
it's somewhat I think works here though
it doesn't work that great
um as we'll look at when we look at the
sweep results but then kind of getting
to the hyper parameter sweep so you can
see also here instead of just putting
specific values in here
um
I'm actually putting in stuff from
another configuration which is the sweep
configuration so these are different uh
parameters we want to sweep over so we
will sweep over batch size 200 400
different number of layers
different learning rates different
forecast history length different number
of kernels different
uh
dimensions of the models and different
amounts of drawn out
um so yeah it's basically
that's what happens there
um and then we can go to the sweep URL
so I think this sweep as always this
might be one of the ones
um I have a bunch of ones that succeeded
so
um
we'll see you know so this one ran
essentially 116 different configurations
and so we can see compare different
losses from different models
um there's here's and since we're
forecasting Force things here's
different models trying to forecast the
temperature uh on different days
um there's different models trying to
forecast to do uh the dew point
um some are doing it better than others
um
and
uh but again yeah we should be able to
pull up some of the better models
um
yeah uh so you can see there's a wide
variety of actually different forecasts
based on the oh that those hyper
parameter selections and stuff
um
uh so um the hyper parameters really do
matter so we can actually sort and sort
these by test loss to see what in series
should be some of the better models
um I'm gonna go make sure I select the
right type of tests
so uh it looks like our test squash was
um
penalized useless yeah yeah uh yeah that
yeah that was that was our Criterion I
don't know if I plotted a different way
yeah
um
oh yeah we just use regular MSC for this
so um
teslost.mse so this in series should
show some of the better models now
um well this one doesn't look that good
uh well see here we can see it has
pretty big confidence interval
um
so it doesn't really
but actually this is somewhat useful
because this is actually forecasting 336
time steps into the future so you can
see initially it's pretty certain that
the prediction should fall of viewpoint
should fall in this range and as it goes
on the confidence interval gets wider
and wider so actually that's not really
that bad
um per se I think
um
there
yeah and again here's cubic footage it
looks like it starts the prediction
starts off really close but then over
time the confidence interval gets wider
and it gets further away
um it's not able clearly here to predict
precipitation well but precipitation is
kind of a hard thing to predict without
I think more geographical figures
because it will suddenly be zero then
have a huge Spike like here
um
so so yeah that's kind of an example of
that so we do see that like some of the
better models that's weird how the
actual loss shot up for a while here
that's the only thing I
wonder about with this model
the regular so we can see
um so that's some of the predictions it
made were good and it's overall test
loss is low in the end so
that might be a model we might want to
invest
um
excuse me though clearly it's still
probably not great for very long range
forecasts like you're I don't think
that's very useful for that many time
steps into the future
um anyway so that that kind of covers
um I guess some different examples of
using flow forecast
um
yes I can
I guess now I'll go finish the rest of
my slides and then we can go over have a
nice long q a session
um
and then yeah
so okay so that was what I just showed
future directions so
um you know we're always seeing bigger
bigger better kind of deep learning
models come out but I actually think
some of the and these can be appealing
in a lot of ways but I think some of the
cool stuff that's actually coming out
that might help some of these problems
more is on the end of like knowledge
infused models that are actually a
synthesis of deep learning and kind of
no and things because there's still a
lot of basic intuitive knowledge that
neural Nets are often getting wrong even
some of these really huge models we
don't all have huge data sets so
um so yeah so again future directions
I think I do think forecasting multiple
regions at once is going to become a lot
bigger or at least there already are
models that do that I'm just working on
getting the data voters to work right in
full forecast
um because it became more complicated
with the loss and everything when you do
that
um so I'm trying to put it uh so our
framework automatically does that and
you don't have to worry about that
um but then as I was saying the move
towards Hybrid models neural Odes Fusion
of knowledge
um you know one of the cool models I
remember from my when I worked on the
coved forecasting was they actually did
a hybrid of the Steer model which is an
epidemiological model and a neural
network and I think that by far
um the group that came up with that
outperformed any of the pure neural
networks or the pure
epidemiological models so kind of a
neural network that can then estimate
some of the parameters of kind of known
um differential equations or other
models is really useful and likewise
with the Stream flow forecasting I think
that might help with the model not
really you know as you saw even with
some of the better models that didn't
really know that precipitation because
it rained so little would like cause the
river flow to go up which most of us
could intuitively say
um so like a neural ode might be a lot
better with that they can also help for
kind of irregular regularly sample data
then again models that can synthesize
non-temporal data or other modalities of
kind of data so over time we're going to
actually I think see a Confluence
because most things if you think about
it have a temporal aspect like you could
have words that change over time to or
text status
or like obviously video so I think more
uh time series forecasting methods have
been almost exclusively kind of uh
numerical to this point but you're going
to see a synthesis of more modalities of
data into them which is a really
interesting research area of course with
that there's going to be a lot more
complexity
um they finally wrap neural networks uh
um I really like some of the recent
papers on graph neural networks
unfortunately pre-processing data to be
in that vertices format is very
complicated and confusing I'm hoping at
some point to also integrate that into
flow forecast that's more intuitive but
there have been a lot of great kind of
results from gnns of learning these
geospatial temporal dependencies well
you know and you know a lot of Time
series problems do have some spatial
components where you have different time
series and different places or even uh
you know even like something that does
isn't like geospatial you might have
some spatial component uh so
um oh yeah I guess one more thing I'd
add too is that I think another big area
too as I said is uh also um I didn't
list it here but also interpretability
methods I kind of touched on some of
that with the shop stuff but shops isn't
great with interpretability so I think
we need better ideas of like what the
neural networks are doing at each
individual layer because I've actually
checked some of my models and sometimes
even a bad model like the
representations are really good the
intermediate representations if I look
at specific layers are really good but
then the end forecast comes out bad so
it was is interesting to see why there's
the disconnect there
um so yeah anyways uh that's kind of it
for my structured presentation but yeah
I definitely want to delve into
questions and stuff like that
[Applause]
it was awesome
um so yeah I'm just gonna pass this
microphone around any
questions
you mentioned that uh the performance
between models can be hugely variable
and depends on the data you're talking
about if you're trying to predict a
thing that you do not know yet which is
what makes these valuable is there a
principled way to pick one versus
another based on the shape of the data
um yeah well so it it really depends
both the kind of I guess shape of data
and how much data you have
um the thing yeah basically what the
large Transformer models uh really take
a ton of data to make them work well so
if for me with transformed miles unless
I have usually at least 50 000 rows or
something I don't even bother to begin
looking at them that's I mean you might
do more or less but that's kind of been
my rule also I think a single
Transformers is you if you do do
Transformers you have to accept that
you're going to spend a lot of time
hyper parameter searching and stuff like
you might spend days with that like I
think sometimes Transformers in the end
might outperform you know some of these
basic model basically grew or lstm but
like the question is like how much
compute resources do you want to use to
find like those exact like hyper
parameters that work
you back here
um thank you so much for the talk and uh
specifically irregular space data on
on what is the what is the advantage
about using your network model as
opposed to let's say like gaussian
process it so like it doesn't make sense
to make
apply Collision processors to kind of
like incurity on unsampled area and then
apply the um the model
um well yeah neural networks uh can work
on uh
wait were you asking about uh variable
length data or regularly
um
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
irregularly sample data right now I
think is pretty hard for you know what
networks because there's at least some
structure to the inconsistency you need
in this for them there was a good paper
as I said on the neural ode front they
create a a Groove that also used kind of
like an ode and it was able I forget
exactly how it was done but it was able
to actually overcome some of those
limitations
um so but that's the only real success
I've known of new
um using deep warning I'm really
irregularly sampled data
um so like in that sense like I think
the ocean processes might at this point
still be easier
um but I think over time we might see
more models that address that so
oh I actually have a question also so
some of the data I deal with has
multiple levels of seasonality so you
have three different types of
seasonalities at the same time and I
found a lot of the classical models
aren't very good at dealing with that
um
have you found a way to to deal with
that with these kind of more complicated
neural network models or does your
package
do that yeah well I guess part of it is
going to be yeah the features you
generate from those so like as I said
you can generate those different date
time features and you can also there's a
way to generate them cyclically so
they're like
ghost on which helps a bit though really
for neural networks to learn seasonality
they need to have like a lot of examples
over time of that so like obviously you
only have data for one year and you try
to train like on your own network on it
to learn like say Christmas shopping
patterns is probably not going to do
that well so you do need to feed a lot
of data
any more questions
oh sorry
thanks um I guess for the some of these
future models this is going to be
everybody needs a super computer
everybody needs like five gpus in their
laptop some of them are going to be
require less compute maintenance right
what's your thought on that actually
I'll just go buy crypto mining stuff
yeah I mean I think uh
the train went from scratch they'll
probably uh require
us a ton of compute obviously I think
what will happen probably as we get a
bit better at like transfer learning and
hover stuff in the time series spaces it
will probably converge to someone like
Bert
I'm still waiting for them to come out
with one with a lamp but I think over
time they'll probably be these
pre-trained models that we'll often use
and then we'll fine-tune them to a
different time series to ask that would
be my guess
um though so far it's proven more
difficult I guess to do that type of
transfer
series than an NLP I still think it's
heading that way slowly
cool also just a comment a lot of the
stuff here was run on kaggle notebooks
which have gpus you can just access gpus
for free so that's I've always found
that to be a good resource
um cool any other questions
once and twice cool all right let's
thank Isaac again
[Applause]